MIRA GRANT: So hello.
I'm Mira Grant.
That's Mira Grant's
mom in the back,
pretending she's not here
with all of us weirdos.
[LAUGHTER]
And I am here today
because I was asked to be,
which is a great reason to
be at the Google campus.
So I'm going to be
reading to you today
from "When Will You Rise," which
is a short hardcover I put out
a couple years ago.
Because its got some pieces
in it that are actually
a good length to read and don't
leave you going wait, what?
The last timed reading
I did, I stopped
in the middle of a word.
To be fair, it was
a very long word
that I didn't want
to pronounce anyway.
But it was still
sort of a jarring
for the people involved.
After the reading,
we're going to have
a brief Q&A. I know some
of you all have books.
I have a pen.
I am happy to scribble
on your books.
I'm actually happy to scribble
on just about anything.
If you really work the Q&A, we
might engage the whiteboard.
So think of questions
that will require
diagramming sentences
or explaining
how the R0 works and
we will go there.
So this is "Apocalypse
Scenario, #683, The Box."
"Andy, where's the beer?"
"Look in the crisper."
Ryan paused before
asking the obvious.
"Why is the beer
in the crisper?"
"Because grain's a vegetable."
said Elsa, sensibly enough,
as she dumps tortilla chips
into a yellow plastic bowl.
"That means beer
is good for you."
"I don't even know
what to say to that,"
said Ryan, before digging a beer
out from under a wilted head
of lettuce.
"Is Mike coming?"
"Mike's coming, Cole isn't."
Andy picked up the
tray of sandwiches,
pausing to kiss
Elsa on the cheek
before exiting the kitchen.
The tray of sandwiches
was placed ceremonious
on the dining room table,
next to a veggie platter,
a bowl of salsa, and a second
bowl filled with peanut M&Ms.
He glanced back, as Ryan
followed him to the table,
adding, "Before you
ask," Sandi's coming.
"She just had to stop and
pick up some root beer."
"Right."
Ryan sat in his usual
chair, cracking open
his first beer of the evening.
He'd stop after the third,
when Sandi's nagging became
too much for him to handle.
None of this was a
mystery to anyone.
And that was how all
of them liked it.
Playing the Apocalypse
Game for 15 years
had transformed predictability
into one of the weekly game
night's greatest attractions.
Spend some time
with your friends,
play a board game you
didn't really care about,
and plot the
downfall of mankind.
Pure bliss.
Cole's absence was
the only black spot
on what was otherwise shaping
up to be a perfect evening.
She'd been more and more
scarce over the past few years,
as for job, which she
never described in detail,
been willing to say
nothing beyond "I work
for the government" and "I
still use my medical degree,"--
kept her away from home
more and more often.
Even saying that much made
her visibly uncomfortable,
until they all stopped asking.
Still, Cole missing
the Apocalypse Game
was a new phenomenon-- new
enough to be unnerving.
Out of all the players, she'd
always been the most reliable.
"Remember the time Cole
had pneumonia," asked Ryan?
She missed two
sessions in a row.
"And then she showed up for the
third session in her bathrobe."
Andy laughed.
"Mike was so
disappointed when he
realized she had her
clothes on underneath it."
"Those were the days."
Ryan took a long swig from
his beer, amusement fading.
"This is the third session.
She's never missed three."
"There's a first
time for everything."
"I'm worried about
her," said Elsa,
emerging from the kitchen
with the bowl of chips.
"She's been working too much.
She needs the Apocalypse Game
to take her mind off things."
Ryan snorted.
"I'm going to give
you a second to think
about what you just said."
"I stand by it.
Cole started the game.
She should be able to
find the time to play."
"I'm sure she'll be back as
soon as she can," said Andy.
"I hope so."
Elsa sighed.
"Maybe Mike can tell us more."
"Maybe," Andy agreed dolefully.
Silence descended.
Their little social group was
just like a thousand others,
all over the world, at
least superficially.
A bunch of old friends
getting together
to play games and
talk until well
after any sensible
person's bed time.
They met in high school, a
bunch of strange, smart kids,
living on the fringes
of teenage society.
They clustered together
in self-defense,
as much as anything else.
It wasn't until midway
through freshman
year that they all started
to actually like each other.
The first Apocalypse Game
was practically an accident.
They've been lazing
around Cole's house, bored
and restless and looking
for something to do.
They tried everything
from poker to Candy Land,
until Cole made her
characteristically mild
suggestion.
"Why don't we figure out
how to destroy the world?"
The first scenario
was Cole's, of course.
It involved a chemical spill
wiping out the world's plankton
supply.
Without plankton, the small fish
died; without the small fish,
the big fish died;
without the big fish,
everything else in the
ocean followed suit.
It was an ineffective,
inelegant apocalypse.
And after they'd spent the
whole night debating it,
Ryan said he could do better.
Elsa dared him to prove it.
A week later he did.
Sandi took the week after
that, and so on, and so on.
High school ended.
College began.
Dan and Tony moved away.
Elsa and Andy got married.
Cole and Mike didn't, although
they may as well have.
And always, always
there was the game.
Maybe it was a
strange way to spend
15 years of Friday nights.
At the end of the day,
none of them really cared.
The five players
took their seats
around the dining room table.
The chair next to Mike
remained conspicuously empty.
None of them could avoid
glancing at it at least once.
Cole's absence was palpable.
And it couldn't be ignored, no
matter how hard everyone tried.
She should've been there.
Mike cleared his throat.
"I, uh, brought something.
Well, Cole sent something."
"Beyond her love, her
regrets, and a promise
that she'll do her best
to make it next week,"
asked Sandi, reaching
for her second root beer.
"If you run out,
we're not stopping
so you can go for
more," said Andy.
Sandi shot him a
glare. "I know that."
Elsa raised a hand, stopping
the familiar argument
before it could begin.
"What did she send?"
"Well, Sandi was
right about Cole
sending her love
and her regrets.
She also sent this."
Mike pulled a digital
recorder from his pocket
and set it down on the
table, between the tortilla
chips and the veggie platter.
"Tonight's supposed to
be her turn, right?"
"Right," said Ryan dubiously.
"So what?
She's going to
present her scenario
and record our discussion?"
"No.
Cole's presenting
her own scenario.
I'm here to play the game."
Mike pressed the Play button.
The recorder beeped once before
Cole's sweet, always slightly
distracted voice came
through the speaker,
just as clear as if she'd
actually been there.
"Hi guys.
I'm sorry I couldn't be
there in person tonight.
But I had things I
needed to take care of.
This is a scenario I've
been working on for a while,
and I think it's pretty solid.
"There will be beeps every
few minutes, like this one"--
the recorder beeped again-- "to
signal that it's time to pause
for discussion
before you continue.
I think I've predicted
all your responses.
You could still surprise me."
There was a third beep.
Mike leaned forward and
paused the recording.
"Well, is everybody
cool with this?"
"It's weird," said Ryan.
"Weird is good."
Sandi giggled nervously.
"I guess it's OK.
I didn't want to skip
her turn anyway."
"Andy, Elsa?"
"I'm cool with it, sure.
But do you know what's on
the recording?" asked Andy?
"Not to be a stickler,
but scenarios
aren't supposed to be
shared before the game."
"She recorded the
whole thing at work
and gave it to me before
she left for the airport,"
said Mike.
"I'm not a cheater.
I didn't listen."
"Then I'm cool with it
too," said Elsa firmly.
"Play the scenario."
Mike pressed the button.
"If you're listening
to this, that
means you've decided
to let me take my turn.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Anyway, this is
Apocalypse Scenario #683.
I've never been good with names.
I'm more interested
in the science.
So I call this
scenario, The Box."
"Sounds promising," said Sandi,
and took a swig of root beer.
Ryan motioned for
her to be quiet.
She stuck her tongue out at him.
Cole's voice
continued, implacably.
"First, establishment
of the scenario.
The Box is based around a
man-made bacterial pandemic.
At the time the scenario
begins, the bacteria in question
have already been released
into the human population
at several geographically
distinct locations.
All the locations
were in North America.
But they all included
a very high probability
of intercontinental
transmission within 24 hours,
as in Andy's Ticket
to Die apocalypse."
"Cute," said Andy.
"The bacterial strain
you're dealing with
was designed by a young
researcher employed
by the bioterrorism division of
the United States government.
It was originally commissioned
under the auspices
of counterterrorism."
Cole's voiced turned
briefly bitter,
causing Andy and Elsa to
exchange worried glances.
Bitterness wasn't native
to Cole's state of being.
"The people in charge
lied about it, of course.
That is vital to
understanding the scenario.
It begins with the assumption
that if you reported
the scenario to the
government, they believe you.
Because the government
is the reason
the situation exists
in the first place."
The recorder beeped.
Mike hit the Pause button.
"There's our set-up."
"It's pretty simplistic,
especially for Cole,"
said Ryan.
"Somebody drops a test tube.
Somebody else tells
the people in charge.
And everything gets mopped
up, with minimal loss of life.
The world doesn't end."
"Nobody dropped a
test tube," said Elsa.
"She said it was released
into the human population
in 'several geographically
diverse locations,' and implied
that they were chosen to create
the widest possible infection
pattern.
This thing was
intentionally released."
"The government angle still
makes it simple," said Andy.
Sandi shrugged.
"So it will be a
short apocalypse.
Go ahead and press Play, Mike.
I want to hear what comes next."
Mike nodded and
pressed the button.
The bitterness was gone, when
Cole resumed her explanation.
Instead, she sounded cheerful,
if a little over tired.
"Second, elaboration
of the scenario.
You're looking at a
bacterial infection based
on the combination of whooping
cough and tuberculosis,
just like Ryan's
No Air apocalypse.
Only this time, the
bacteria has been
tailored for
antibiotic resistance.
"The first generation has
an artificially long latency
built in, to allow
for extensive spread.
Once the first
generation of bacteria
have incubated to
maturity in human lungs,
the latency will be halved,
until the final projected
generation, where it will
default to the standard latency
period for whooping cough.
Symptoms include coughing,
runny nose, headache,
difficulty breathing, muscular
spasms, secondary pneumonia,
and, of course, death.
Fatality estimates
place the death toll
at approximately 91% of
the infected population.
It's impossible to accurately
project susceptibility.
The projections indicate that
as much as 80% of the human race
could be infected by the
end of the second latency."
Beep.
Pause.
"OK.
That's charming."
Sandi wrinkled her nose.
"Has Cole off her
meds or something?
She's not normally this
nasty with her scenarios."
Mike didn't say anything.
He reached almost
mechanically for the chips,
scooping up a handful.
His eyes look haunted.
Something about that
look frightened Andy,
in ways he wasn't sure
he could put into words.
Something was wrong.
"Mike," he said, "you OK, buddy?
Is Cole OK?"
"She's been working
a lot lately."
Mike forced a laugh.
"She's just
stressed, that's all.
Let's keep going."
He hit the button before
anyone could object.
And Cole spoke again.
"Three-- three,
explanation of apocalypse
stemming from scenario.
Buckle up, guys.
Here's where the
real game starts.
"See, this researcher, she was
recruited right out of college.
Her scholarship
to medical school,
wasn't a scholarship,
not really;
it was a government loan.
They'd pay for
everything and she'd
go to work for them
when she graduated.
They wanted her that much,
because she was that good."
Something like pride
crept into Cole's voice.
"They knew she'd be able
to change the world."
Elsa's hand clamped down on
Andy's elbow, squeezing hard.
None of them said anything.
"For a while, she was
happy with the deal.
She thought she was protecting
the world against the bad guys.
That she could stave
off the apocalypse
she'd been worrying about
since she was in high school.
She tore viruses and bacteria
apart and recombined in ways
no one else has ever
been able to accomplish.
"She read.
She researched.
She was going to
change the world.
Only it turned out she had.
Because she started hearing
about this outbreak in Korea,
that perfectly mirrored
one of her projects,
one of her defensive projects.
People were dying
of something that
sounded a lot like her enhanced
strain of bubonic plague.
"She went to her superiors
and asked them-- asked them
if they were going to send help.
And they told her to go back to
her lab and get back to work."
"I saw that on the
news," whispered Elsa.
So many people died."
Cole continued.
"She got scared
then, our researcher.
And she started really
looking at the things she'd
been working on, the things that
were supposed to help people.
Only they weren't
helping people at all.
They were hurting them.
And everyone said
that was OK because we
weren't the only ones.
"Every government in
the world was doing it.
And that made it OK.
That made it necessary.
Because if we didn't build
it, someone else would."
She stopped, seeming to
her place for a moment,
before repeating,
"Someone else would.
It wasn't something she could
stop by walking away, you know.
It was going to happen.
We'd made it inevitable.
She'd made it inevitable.
"So maybe the best
thing she could do
was stop it all before
it got even worse.
Stop it the only
way she knew how.
Stop the whole damn
arms race for awhile
and give everyone a
chance to breathe.
For certain values
of every one, anyway.
Because if she didn't--
"Things had been getting
worse for a long time.
Everybody knows that.
If humanity isn't
stopped, they're
going to kill the planet,
not just themselves.
Someone had to do something.
She was just the one watching
when the time finally came."
Beep.
Pause.
"This is sick," said
Sandi, glaring at Mike.
"Why is she doing this?
There's not even
anything to discuss.
It's just sick, Mike."
Elsa worried her lip between
her teeth for a moment,
before saying, "Cole never
told us who she worked for."
"No."
Mike's voice was bleak.
"She wasn't allowed to.
They made her sign
a lot of papers."
"A lot of papers in exchange
for what?" asked Andy.
"Medical school."
Mike pressed the button.
"The release happened
six days ago.
The infection has a
latency of 23 days.
Additional releases
are ongoing because--"
Cole stopped again,
before starting back up,
sounding more and more
like a broken marionette.
She was running down.
"Because the government
funded the original project,
they might be able
to find a vaccine
if they start
looking immediately.
It wouldn't be hard to
type the bacterial strain.
And there are only a few
researchers working with it.
They don't know about all
the modifications that I--
that she-- that were made.
"They'd need to
start right away.
But there's a catch."
"Isn't there
always?" asked Mike.
"The researcher who
created the disease,
she's listening in on
all the big channels
and a lot of the small ones.
She has people feeding
her information.
People who have really good
reason to be loyal to her.
People who see the
same solution she does.
"And if she hears a whisper
from any government, anywhere,
that links this pandemic
to her research,
she'll release the second
project she worked on,
the bad one."
"This isn't the bad one?"
Ryan sounded incredulous.
"I mean, come on, Cole."
"Here's where things
get dicey, guys.
See, the second virus
isn't bacterial.
It's an actual virus based on
a hemorrhagic out of Africa,
called Lassa fever.
It's got a long latency
and a high mortality.
And that's without clever
virologists playing
with the way it works.
"And this one hasn't
got a vaccine.
Although it does have a
nasty little interlock
with the vaccine for
the bacterial strain.
If you would have been immune
to the original pandemic,
either naturally or
due to immunization,
you'll get the second
virus and you'll die."
Cole sighed deeply.
"I'm sorry about that."
"Is she crazy?" demanded Sandi?
"I don't know," said Ryan.
Cole's laughter
startled them all.
Even Mike, who
jumped in his chair
and nearly knocked
over Sandi's root beer.
It was a brittle, jagged
sound, like broken glass.
"OK.
OK.
I give, you guys," she said.
"This 'oh, I have a friend,'
shit is so high school,
isn't it?
I built the virus.
I built them both.
"The scenario is still valid.
The releases started last
week, Manhattan, San Francisco,
and best of all, Disney World.
I put it in misters, just like
Elsa's Black Fungus apocalypse.
"Thanks for that, Elsa.
It works great."
Elsa looked ill.
Cole kept talking.
"I love you guys.
You're the best
friends I've ever had.
I mean you may be the only
friends I've ever had,
the only real ones anyway.
That's why I'm leaving
this up to you.
"I vaccinated you all against
the first disease months ago.
You're probably the safest
people on the planet.
Yes, even you Sandi.
I know you slept with Mike.
But I don't really care
about that anymore.
It's too trivial a concern."
Sandi and Mike
exchanged a glance.
Her eyes wide and horrified.
His, merely resigned.
Cole kept talking.
"You're all going to live
through what comes next.
It won't be fun.
But you'll live.
"I knew you wouldn't
want to do it alone.
You're always more
social than I was.
So I've arranged to have a box
couriered to Elsa and Andy's
place tonight, during the game.
"Inside, you'll find 10 doses
of vaccine for each of you.
Use them however you want.
Save your family, or your
friends, or your doctor.
It's up to you.
"You can even give
them to the government.
And if you do, I'll die
with you because I'm
immune to the first
pandemic, just like you are."
Cole's voice turned wistful.
"I wish I could have given
you the scenario in person.
I think it's the best one
I've ever put together.
I really wanted to.
But in the end, I
couldn't risk it.
I love you all, you all so much.
"I hope you'll find the
answer that's right.
Because to be honest, I can't.
All I can do is end
the world and let
you decide how much
of it survives.
This is Cole Evans signing out."
A pause.
And then in a
whisper they all had
to strain hear, "Forgive me."
The recorder beeped
one more time.
Silence fell.
Ryan was the first to react.
He laughed nervously.
"OK wow.
That's the best mind fuck
we've had in a while."
He points to Cole.
"I don't think she was
kidding," said Elsa.
"We haven't answered the
scenario yet guys," said Mike.
"Do we call the
government and die or do
we condemn millions of
people because we're
too chicken to pick up a phone?"
"Dude, did you really sleep
with Sandi?" asked Ryan.
Mike didn't answer.
"Won't calling the government
mean killing even more people,"
asked Andy.
She said the second
virus was worse."
"We don't know if
that," said Mike.
"Maybe there's only one virus."
"Because Cole was always an
underachiever." said Ryan.
"If she says there's a
second virus in the scenario,
there's a second
virus in the scenario.
I'm just not buying the
idea that it's real life."
"Are you willing to
risk it?" asked Elsa.
"We're not risking
anything," snapped Sandi.
"It's a game.
It's a stupid game.
And that's all its ever been and
that's also we're going to be.
"Stop taking this so seriously.
Cole is just messing with us.
That's all."
The doorbell rang.
Silence fell again, thick and
heavy as a curtain going down.
Elsa looked around the group,
meeting everyone's eyes
in turn.
Then she slowly pushed the
chair back from the table,
stood, and walked
to answer the door.
She was halfway across the
room when the person outside
began to cough.
So that is The Box.
I did that to my
friends for a year.
Like I'd literally go,
if you have no reason
to believe I didn't just wipe
out mankind, what would you do?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm a great friend.
My friend Sean, said he
would go out in the street,
vaccinate first 10 strangers
he saw, and then eat a bullet.
Because.
If I actually done this,
he had failed somehow
to stop me before I
could get that far.
And I went, that's
the best response.
So does anybody
have any questions?
OK.
So everybody's freaking
out about Ebola.
Ebola.
Ebola is nasty.
We do not like Ebola.
It's very tragic that it's
killing a lot of people.
And it's really too bad that
we don't have a good vaccine.
But the problem with the Ebola
is that it has a very low R0.
Now, the R0 is how many
people you can conceivably
pass the virus along to before
you die a horrible death
or are somehow no longer
infectious, but still alive.
If you manage the
second, congratulations.
The R0 of Ebola,
on average, is two.
So you can pass it
to two more people.
And that's with an
absolutely idealized chain
of transmission.
So you managed to bleed,
spit, cry, or piss
on two other people
before you're just dead.
This is why I usually tell
folks that are not actually
medical professionals, that
if you want to avoid Ebola,
just don't lick people.
The flu, on the
other hand-- and this
is why we're all getting
our flu shots this year,
unless we have a good
medical reason not to.
Any guesses on
the R0 of the flu?
AUDIENCE: 500.
MIRA GRANT: No.
Not quite that good.
But it has an
estimated R0 of 10.
So every case of the flu
is good for a minimum
of 10 additional cases.
And what's really
great about the flu is
that it is, unlike Ebola,
which is purely body fluid
transmissible,
fomite transmissible.
Fomites mean that
anything that's
been touched by our initial
carrier, anything at all,
is now also infectious and
can add to that R0 of 10.
So we've got 10 from the
people you breathe on
and then an additional three
from stuff you touched.
Yeah.
So get your flu shots.
10,000 Americans will die of
the flu this year, 10,000.
That's actually not a
good reason to be smiling.
I just always am when I'm
talking about the flu.
It's like a nervous tic.
So that's R0.
The R0 is great.
The R0 is the reason
that sexually transmitted
diseases are
sexually transmitted
and not caught in other ways.
They usually have a very low R0.
AUDIENCE: So you wrote that
song about the Black Death,
like 10 years ago.
And just recently, I
started seeing articles
that are vindicating what you
were espousing in that song.
How do you feel about that?
MIRA GRANT: I feel
real good because I
had a-- the song
she's referring to,
the song about the Black Death.
It's actually called
the "Black Death."
And it is roughly eight minute
long, schoolhouse, rock-style
song, explaining why
the causative agent
for the Black Death
in Europe was probably
not yersinia pestis, or the
bubonic plague bacterium,
as most people believed.
But was, instead, an
unidentified hemorrhagic fever,
that had traveled up the Nile
River to the Middle East,
and then made the jump
to Messina, Italy.
But I literally took
all of the science
on the side of the
hemorrhagic fever theory,
or rather about
80% of the science
on the hemorrhagic fever
theory, and boiled it down
into cheerful rhyming verses.
Like, well, we
blamed it on the rats
and we blamed it on the fleas.
We were ignoring crucial facts
about the speed of the disease.
And I think it's time
we call for a more
thorough inquisition.
Because it's clear that
the Black Death possessed
a droplet-based transmission.
Now, a droplet-based
transition means I sneeze
and then you die.
It's a fairly common vector.
And we think that's largely
why the quarantine developed
to protect us from
diseases and to help
to keep your family from
dying of my sneezes.
So it's eight minutes of that.
[LAUGHTER]
And it goes into a lot of very
strong evidentiary support
for the hemorrhagic
fever theory.
The main reason I think
we should be considering
this information isn't because
we're somehow magically going
to bring back the thousands
of people if we say,
oh, it's wasn't bubonic plague.
You can get out
of your grave now.
But because when we take
this stuff just as a given,
when we say, oh, it absolutely
was this bacteria that we
can easily cure today, we become
a lot less respectful of things
like plague pits, that
are still all over Europe.
Some of which are in good
permafrost conditions
for the preservation of
virological sustainability.
You crack one of those puppies
open, we could all die.
There was a study published,
I think, four years ago now,
where this one German consortium
said, yes, absolute proof.
We did a core sample
in a known plague pit.
And we found yersinia
pestis bacterium.
So everyone who says that
it's not yersinia pestis
is wrong and can go home.
And by the way, it's totally
OK for the people who
funded the study to
dig up the plague pits
and run a high-speed rail right
through the middle of them.
We all live in California.
If you've lived in California
for more than eight months,
you have been exposed to the
yersinia pestis bacteria.
You probably have it in
the pulp of your teeth.
Because that's one of the
places that it builds up.
So if I were to yank a molar
from every person in this room,
before Google security
arrested me for assault,
I could test them and find
proof that yersinia pestis was
endemic on the Google campus.
And thus, clearly, that is what
had killed you all, and not
the crazy woman with the pliers.
So there's very strong
evidence for hemorrhagic fever.
There's very little
evidence for bubonic plague.
There's actually more evidence
on the hemorrhagic fever
side of things, which is kind
of fascinating when you really
start digging into it.
But everyone accepts that
it was bubonic plague.
Why?
Because their third grade
history teacher told them
it was bubonic plague.
And that is very sloppy
thinking scientifically.
Now, as she mentioned
here, in the front row,
in the last problem
couple of years,
as more people started
really looking at this
because somebody finally
realized, wait, plague pit?
Let's not dig that up.
Hey.
So they started
really looking at it
and realizing that there's
some strong evidence
to support the idea that
this was a novel virus.
And not only that, but
it was a novel virus
we have not encountered
again, as yet.
Which is part of what is
driving up the interest,
as more and more
novel viruses are
emerging from their
natural habitats
and interacting with humanity.
If we assume that the
Black Death was something
that made the transition from
the Middle East, to Europe--
and we have a very strong
chain to prove that-- we have
the landing and departure
records for the ship
that is widely accepted
as the first point
of entry for the Black
Death into Europe.
And it sailed out of
Jerusalem, into Messina, Italy.
Yes.
We've got great support.
That could come back.
It could come to visit us again.
And we would be looking
at a hemorrhagic fever,
with a fatality rate
of approximately 97%,
an R0 of an estimated 15 to
25, and a latency period of 31
days.
Yay.
So I'm very excited that
all this is coming up.
It's great.
I love the Black Dance song.
I have a huge amount
of affection for it
because that song is the
reason the CDC started
talking to me at
all when I was doing
the research my
first zombie novel.
I called and said hi.
My name is Seanan McGuire.
Because that is
my real name and I
had not become Mira Grant yet.
Hi.
My name is Seanan McGuire.
And I want to write
a book about zombies.
And do you have any
researchers that
would be willing to talk
about diseases with me?
And they were like, no.
This is the CDC.
We don't get-- Oh.
OK.
Well, anybody says that
they might be willing to,
can I leave an
email address just
in case someone's like bored?
Oh, fine.
We'll take your info
if you'll go away.
And so I start spelling my name
and the lady goes wait, wait.
That's how you pronounce that?
[LAUGHTER]
Are you the Black Death girl?
I'm like, what?
And she says, did you write
a song about the Black Death?
Yes.
I'm going to put you on speaker.
Prove it.
So I had to say the
entire Black Death
song for the secretarial
pool at the CDC.
And then magically,
eight doctors
were happy to talk to me.
So a great deal of
affection for that song.
AUDIENCE: How did you
get into diseases?
MIRA GRANT: Well, I caught some.
And that was pretty neat.
I have OCD.
So I have some of the issues
that people with OCD have.
And I realized, when
I was in high school,
that I was verging on
becoming a germaphobe.
That I was starting
to get really,
really twitchy and upset
when anyone was sick,
with anything, anywhere near me.
And at that point,
I kind of sat down
and went, OK, this is nascent.
This is becoming an obsession.
We can either have it
be the kind of obsession
where I wind up
living in a bubble
or we can have it become
the kind of obsession
where I think that jamming my
hand into a bucket of maggots
is fun.
Bubble?
Maggots?
I like maggots.
Bubble?
Oh, let's go over there.
So I started reading
up on diseases
and learning everything
I could because I
wanted to shift to
burgeoning obsession
over to understanding.
Basically, if I knew
enough about them,
I would still be afraid of them.
But it would be a
respectful fear, rather than
in irrational fear.
And I was lucky in that
I did it at the time.
I knew several
folks that did, not
who were in a couple
of counseling circles
with me, in group therapy,
who can't touch things now.
Like they can't pee in public.
They can't share food because
they've gotten so frightened.
Whereas I'm like,
nah, I know the odds.
It's all good.
Let's get tapeworms.
It's a party.
So I started studying them.
I kind of thought about
going to medical school
for a little while.
But the money just
wasn't there, sadly.
If it had been, I think I'd be
working for EIS by this point
and having a lovely time,
going off into the jungle,
and kicking things to see
if they're full of Ebola.
We still don't know where
the Ebola comes from.
So that is an ongoing
party that just is rolling.
It eats up EIS operatives
like nobody's business.
But viruses and diseases and
parasites are just fascinating.
Like they're older than we are.
Some of them are so old
that they are actually
a part of our DNA.
If you hear people talk
about junk DNA, the things
that our bodies intentionally
manufacture in our little DNA
factories, and then carry
around, that don't do anything,
some of them are viruses that
are older than the human race.
That we've just kind of
programed in there and now
carry around with us.
We don't know why.
We don't know what
they're doing.
they might do some day.
There's always the
possibility that we're
going to have a genetic
therapy or we're
going to modify
something in such a way
that it unlocks one
of these protoviruses
and we all turn
into snake people.
We don't know.
It's the best thing.
It's like hacking
the human genome.
And I love it.
It makes me so happy.
And it makes it really hard
to have dinner with me,
really, really hard.
AUDIENCE: Back to the CDC.
I was curious what kind
of zombie questions
you had for them?
And were they really helpful?
MIRA GRANT: They were
extremely helpful.
I wanted to put
together a virus that
could actually make "zombies."
They're not zombies in
the narrow sense, where
they died and then resurrected.
Because, frankly,
that doesn't work.
You can write horror
or fantasy about those.
But you can't really
do science fiction
unless they're being controlled
by nanobots or something other
than the body itself.
And I wanted to do
science fiction.
So it's like, OK.
If I gave them all rabies,
would they be zombies?
And the CDC is like,
let's talk about people
that actually have rabies.
Oh.
Well, what if I gave them
rabies mixed with the bird flu?
No.
Well, I heard about
violent behavior
from people that have been
infected with Lassa fever.
What if I gave-- no.
What if I modified
Marburg and combined it
with the virility
of a rhinovirus
and caused it become
completely airborne,
and gave it the entire
population at once,
and caused massive viral
amplification in anything
of over 40 pounds?
Don't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Which really was one
of the best moments.
Was just having the doctor I was
talking to, go don't do that.
Like that's a bad plan
that you have there.
So that's how I got
my zombie virus.
They were very helpful.
I wound up writing
a lot about the CDC.
And they enjoyed the things
I wrote about them very much.
They're like, we never get to
play that role in the story.
Go team, us.
We're evil.
So it was fun.
They're really nice people.
If you ever have the chance
to tour a CDC facility,
I highly recommend it.
It is, in some ways, weirdly
like going to Google.
There's big signs
everywhere that say,
no one that doesn't work
here, past this point.
But on the other side of
that point,m is Marburg.
So I'm assuming that every room
in this building that I'm not
allowed to go in, is
full of deadly viruses.
It makes me feel
very at home here.
AUDIENCE: Seanan, I can
only assume that someone who
writes as much about
apocalypses as you do,
has a post-apocalypse plan.
Would you like to share with us?
MIRA GRANT: No.
[LAUGHTER]
The first rule of
post-apocalyptic survival
is don't talk about where you're
going to be post-apocalypse
because then people
will show up.
I was watching the
science fiction channel.
I spent the day
after Thanksgiving
watching all of the
terrible movies on my DVR.
It was amazing.
Like 13 hours of bad B movies
taped off the science fiction
channel.
And one of them was
called "Mutant World."
And it was terrible.
It was so bad.
It made no sense at all.
It's like what-- no.
Mutation doesn't like that.
But one of the things I thought
was-- there are frequently
moments of startling realism in
science fiction channel movies.
Like it'll be 98%
random bullshit.
And then there's 2%,
where you're like, yeah,
that is exactly
what would happen.
So we opened the movie
with a planet-buster comet
heading toward the East Coast.
And this family of
survivalists, that
are part of a survivalist
organization, that
have been prepping
for something like
this for the last 20
years, scrambling.
Going, OK, everybody.
Go, go, go.
Head for the silo.
Stop at the depot.
Pick up your part.
Bring everyone.
They're writing checklists.
They're getting everyone inside.
Now, these are people, who,
it is made very clear, in just
the five minutes
that we see, everyone
has been making fun
of for 20 years.
Oh, they're the
crazy survivalists.
The fiance of the girl in the
group refuses to go with her.
Because it's just your
dad, doing another drill.
And this is more crazy
survivalist bullshit.
And then, as they are getting
the last of their people
into their silo and
getting ready to lock down,
it becomes impossible
to hide the fact
that the comet is
coming anymore.
I appreciate the
accelerated timeline
because this movie was
not about the comet.
It's about the aftereffects.
We learn all this
in five minutes.
The comet is coming.
The president has admitted
the comet is coming.
And is saying, ah, go to your
basement, you'll be fine.
And everyone who lives in
the city around the silo, who
knows about the crazy
survivalists, comes running.
They get a Black Friday
level rush on their silo
from people going, I
want to get inside.
I want to be where
the safety is.
I want to be where the food is.
Now, the survivalists
have very carefully
constructed this silo.
They're figuring its got to
hold them for the next 20 years.
So there's only so much food.
There's only so much water.
And it's a beautiful
grasshopper and the ants moment,
where the survivalists,
on the one hand,
are being horrible people.
They start gunning
down people that
are getting too
close to their silo.
Who won't turn back when they're
told, no, you have to go.
There is not room.
There are not the resources.
You have to go home.
But the survivalists have also
dedicated the last 20 years
of their life to surviving
a moment like this one.
So who is actually
in the wrong here?
The survivalists, who
are shooting people.
They are committing murder.
But they are
defending themselves
and they are preserving their
families and their future.
Or the people who
spent the last 20
years going, ha, ha,
crazy survivalists?
I'm not going to help you.
I'm not going to
give you money to buy
a place in your structure.
I'm not going to
volunteer some of my time
to have my kids considered.
I'm just going to
laugh at you and then
expect you to help me
when the comet is coming.
So the first rule of a
good survival plan is
don't tell anyone you're
not bringing with you,
about your good survival plan.
Because, unfortunately,
everyone has someone else
they want to keep.
When I was presented
to the story I read,
I really did do that to
my friends for a year.
For a year I'd be
like, OK, imagine
you have no reason to
doubt that I could do this.
What would you do?
And you'd always
get someone that
argued about the number
of doses of vaccine.
You can't just give me 10.
You can't.
I don't mind that you're
wiping out the human race.
But you have to save
these 30 people that
are super-important to me.
And I'm like that is
the kind of thinking
that leads to saving
the entire human race.
That's not my goal here.
When the comet is
coming, you can't
save the entire human race.
I wish you could.
But that's what a comet's for.
Now, you all live in California.
California is the land
of big earthquakes.
We don't have them very often.
But right now,
we're having a lot
of rain, which we're
not used to anymore.
And that is leading to
power outages and mud
slides and other problems.
So when you get home, as you're
thinking about that comet,
think about updating
your earthquake kit.
Get some bottled water in there.
Make sure that you've
got some dry food.
If you're someone that
really requires medication--
you're on
antidepressants, you need
a certain painkiller, whatever--
remember that you can usually
get an extra month from
your pharmacist, just once,
to put in your kit.
Those will be good for a year.
At the end of the year,
when they're 11 months old,
take them out and use them.
And put your new
refill in there.
So you always have a one-month
supply of whatever pills
you need to be alive and
healthy and happy in your kit.
So if there is a disruption that
causes us not to have access
to primary services for
a month, you'll be OK.
So it's harder for diabetics.
And I apologize.
But if it's antidepressants,
you can manage it.
Yay.
I'm the most cheerful author
you'll ever have talk here.
Everybody is going to die.
My poor mom gets deride
back to Concord with me.
I'm all amped up now.
Whoo, death of mankind.
Hi.
You want me to tell you about
the new book, "Symbiont."
The new book is the
sequel to the last book,
which was called "Parasite."
And it's about genetically
engineered tapeworms.
And I had a tapeworm for
a year, to do research.
I went to the Minnesota
Museum of Parasitology.
And they gave it
to me in a pill.
His name was Timmy.
And you have never seen
a horror like the look
on the face of your
dining companion
when you say oh, no, I
get to use the royal "we."
[LAUGHTER]
That is book two of a trilogy.
So the first book
was "Parasite,"
which came out last year.
It's available in both
hardcover and now in paperback.
This is "Symbiont,"
which just came out.
The Tuesday before Thanksgiving,
my bioengineered tapeworm book
comes out.
That's some planning, Orbit.
Yay.
And then, next year about
this time, the third book,
"Chimera," will come out.
And that is it.
We're done.
We're closed.
I finished book three
and turned it in.
What's awful is I did initially
sell this is as a duology.
So halfway through "Symbiont."
I'm calling my agent and
going, we have a problem.
What's the problem?
Remember how I said I
could write a duality?
Yes.
It out I was wrong.
Ha, ha.
Please contact
Orbit and ask them
if they'll let me
publish a third book.
What if they say no?
Then we publish second
book with no ending.
Yay.
But fortunately, they agreed
to let me have a third book.
I really like them.
I am very excited by tapeworms.
I find the hygiene hypothesis
extremely compelling.
The hygiene hypothesis
holds that the reason
for the rise in allergies
and autoimmune disorders
among the population is because
for literally millennia,
humans lived alongside with,
and affected by, parasites.
Almost everyone would
have a parasitic infection
at some point in their
lives, possibly more.
Sometimes they'd just have
systemic parasitic infections
for their entire lives.
And they didn't have
very many allergies.
And they didn't have very
many autoimmune disorders.
These are all relatively recent
developments as far as "human"
goes.
What the hygiene
hypothesis holds
is that our immune systems
evolved to be hypervigilant,
so that they could fight
against those parasites
and keep them from killing us.
So an immune system, in
the absence of a parasite,
is sort of like a five-year-old
boy with a baseball bat,
standing in a room
full of breakable shit.
Now, maybe your
five-year-old boy
will become content just
balancing the bat on his hand
and going whee.
But most five-year-old boys
are going to start going, huh.
OK.
And I will say that during the
year that I have my tapeworm,
I fewer colds and my allergic
reactions were less severe.
There is human testing
going on right now,
with controlled
hookworm infections,
to treat celiac and
Crohn's disease.
AUDIENCE: You talk about
this tapeworm, Timmy--
MIRA GRANT: Timmy.
AUDIENCE: --in the past tense.
MIRA GRANT: Timmy is
no longer with us.
I miss him dearly.
But it's all right
because his ghost still
haunts my digestive tract,
sapping nutrients from my soul,
instead of from my body.
[LAUGHTER]
It took rather more
courses of antiparasitics
than planned to
get rid of Timmy.
So there were a couple
Facebook updates
that only made sense to
a small number of people.
It was like yeah, Timmy's back.
And they were all going
not, that's not yay.
[LAUGHTER]
That is the opposite of yay.
My best friend spent like a year
making me wear gloves or wash
my hands before I
touched anything.
I would wash my hands,
walk out of the bathroom.
And she'd be like no,
go wash your hands.
They're still wet and smell
like-- go wash your hands.
OK.
But Timmy is no longer with us.
Because this is being
recorded for posterity,
please don't ask about the
process of getting rid of Timmy
because you probably
don't want to know.
And I'm pretty sure no one else
in this room wants to know.
I wish I didn't know.
But I'm going to have to
know for the rest of my life.
So no.
Yes, mom.
Mom has her hand up.
Mom would like the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Like roundworm is
passed from person to person.
If you touch someone-- if you
touched the roundworm, how
do you get--?
MIRA GRANT: Well, roundworm
is not actually parasite.
Roundworm is a fungus that
just grow-- seriously.
Roundworm is a fungus
that grows in this shape.
That's why you can get rid
of it with a topical cream.
AUDIENCE: Or fingernail polish.
MIRA GRANT: Or
fingernail polish.
So there are a lot of fun
ways to get parasites.
The most common fun way
of getting a parasite
is what we call fecal/oral.
Guess what he's eating?
Stuff.
And the fun thing about
fecal/oral transmission
is-- did you know
that every time you
flush your toilet without
putting the lid down,
its sends aerosolized toilet
water through the bathroom.
So if your toothbrush is
too close to the toilet,
you're brushing your teeth
with feces every time.
Yay.
Everybody get a
toothbrush cover.
Yay.
And put the freaking lid down.
It's not just a girl thing.
It's "I don't want
your cholera" thing.
There are lots of ways
of getting parasites.
The most common
parasite in the world
is, unfortunately, malaria.
Which is not a thing the
hygiene hypothesis supports
because the malaria
parasite kills you.
And that is so small
that most people catch it
from mosquitoes.
So a mosquito bite passes
the malaria parasite along.
And it lives in your body
and everything gets awful.
We treat malaria as a
disease because it is.
Disease is a very
catch-all word.
But it is a parasitic infection.
Tapeworms are generally gotten
by eating undercooked meat
or by fecal/oral transmission.
If you touch the
dirt in your garden,
and a coyote has peed
there or pooped there,
and then you touch your mouth,
you can get coyote tapeworms.
Every species on Earth
has different tapeworms.
And they all prioritize
a different part
of the body to hang out in.
So like pig tapeworms,
which are trichinosis-- it's
most common kind in humans
right now-- pig tapeworms are
bad because pigs are
so similar to humans,
that pig tapeworms are
like, hey, I can live here.
And they have a little party.
And sometimes they get bored
and they migrate to your brain.
And that's not fun for
anybody, not even the tapeworm.
Because once it's in
there, it can't figure out
how to get out.
It's like, fuck.
It's like going onto the
Google campus for the tapeworm.
It's never getting out.
It is stuck.
It cannot find visitor parking.
It cannot leave.
And it's going to get arrested.
It's terrible.
Coyote tapeworms, on the
other hand, infect your eye.
And once they are
there, they start
chewing holes in your retinas.
Now, you know what
doesn't grow back?
Your retinas.
So you will actually go blind
if you get a coyote tapeworm.
Raccoon tapeworms
go for the liver.
Goat tapeworms are a lot
like the pig tapeworm
in that they parasitize
your digestive system.
But goats are enough
different from humans
that the goat tapeworm
is like-- whaa--
I'm just going to hang on
here and drink some blood.
And hope my mom comes
to pick me up soon.
This sucks.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't
Timmy a goat tapeworm?
MIRA GRANT: Timmy
was a goat tapeworm.
I did not want a tapeworm
that was hugely comfortable
in my body.
I wanted my tapeworm
to understand
that it was a temporary
tenant and was being evicted.
Fish tapeworms, their
entire reproductive cycle
is disrupted by being
in the human body.
They don't know what to do.
So they will actually reproduce
at such a prodigious rate
that they clog up your stomach.
And you can't actually
eat or drink anymore.
You can die of dehydration
because of the number of fish
tapeworms in your stomach.
This is not as good of a
weight loss plan as it sounds.
Tapeworms are great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] terrible.
MIRA GRANT: Oh, yes.
But you'll lose a lot of
weight before the doctor has
to go in and remove
the giant worm, Bezoar,
from your stomach.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, you really know that
if you ask a question,
I say horrible things.
Come on.
I am morally obligated by
the length of the drive
to continue talking for at
least another nine minutes.
Technically, we have an
hour and nine minutes.
But you all are more
interested in laughing
at me than asking me questions.
So that's probably
not going to happen.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So what's better
than taxoplasmosis?
MIRA GRANT: Not
having toxoplasmosis.
AUDIENCE: Come on.
Is there anything
that affects humans
in a more interesting
way than that?
MIRA GRANT: So toxoplasmosis,
which is a parasitic infection
that you get from
your cat, is great.
Because what toxo wants
us to be in a cat.
But a lot of parasites
are kind of like humans.
We grow up in our
parents' houses.
Then we go off to college.
Then we get an apartment.
We don't like the apartment.
So we move back into
our parents houses.
So that's kind of primary
host is the parents' house.
Well, the
toxoplasmosis, it really
wants to live in the cat.
But the eggs and the tiny toxo
get passed out of the cat,
through feces and urine,
and wind up in the cat box.
Well, they don't like it there.
It's kind of terrible there.
So they wait for rats and
mice to come into the cat box,
looking for things to eat,
or just kind of scuttling
over waste, as happens.
And then, hey, I live in
a shitty apartment now.
Its name is Mickey.
And once they're
living in Mickey Mouse,
the toxo goes into
the mouse's brain
and rewires it to take
away the fear of cats.
So mice, rats, squirrels,
anything small,
that would normally
smell cat urine
and be like nope,
nope, nope, nope,
it rewires their brains so
that they're like, oh, cat pee.
I want to see if I can
find the source of that.
And they go looking for cats.
And then they're like hi.
And the cat is like, OK,
schlomp, and eats them.
And the toxo gets to move
back into its parents' house.
This is a great loop if you
happen to be toxoplasmosis.
However, because
humans keep cats,
we have a lot of cat pee
and cat poo in our homes.
And we wind up
interacting with it.
And people can be infected
with toxoplasmosis.
They found that women
with toxoplasmosis
become more outgoing, more
promiscuous, and more likely
to wrap their car around a tree.
Men with toxoplasmosis actually
become less contentious,
more social, more mild,
and a little bit worse
at "World of Warcraft."
Like they've genuinely
found that for women,
it decreases driving
skill and for men it
decreases reaction time.
So you're worse at twitch games.
And where we're worse
at getting home alive.
Now, since we do not
have cats large enough
to eat people anymore--
yet-- for toxoplasmosis,
humans are a dead end.
Toxo does not want to be in us.
Because it can't get out.
It can't get back to
its parents' house.
Unfortunately, it's very hard to
test for toxoplasmosis in cats.
And toxo can be extremely,
extremely dangerous.
Most cases, in adult
humans, in folks
that not immunocompromised,
will be symptomless,
other than the small
personality changes.
Which, let's face it, if you
have enough cats that you've
come into contact with
that much cat pee,
no one's going to notice.
But it can cause blindness.
It can cause serious, serious
danger to unborn children.
So pregnant women, or
women who are attempting
to become pregnant, should
not clean their own cat boxes.
Not being the United
States government,
I will not say women who could
potentially become pregnant,
should not clean cat boxes.
But if you decided, hey,
I want to have a baby,
make your boyfriend
clean the cat box.
That's what he's for.
Or, in my case,
anyone that's not me.
So toxoplasmosis is great.
We actually don't have anything
that modifies human behavior as
severely as toxoplasmosis.
There are a couple
of other parasites
and fungi that mess with other
members of the animal kingdom
that much.
The cordyceps fungus
is very big right now.
Everybody loves codyceps.
Whoo, cordyceps.
But it only reprograms ants.
There's a really great parasitic
barnacle that attacks crabs.
And it is a castrator.
It's a chemical
castration process.
So it gets onto male crabs.
It cuts off their little
crabby testosterone equivalent.
It's not actually testosterone.
I don't remember what
it is because I'm not
a crab scientist.
And then it slowly
rewires the crab
to think that it's a girl crab.
And then once the crab has
decided that it's a girl crab,
the barnacle starts exploding
in the crab baby place.
And then the crab will
spend the rest of its life
nurturing and caring for this
barnacle, that has literally
devoured its sexual organs and
taken it out of the gene pool.
So that's super-fun.
That is not something that
goes for humans-- yet.
Science is a miracle.
Yay.
AUDIENCE: I like hearing
about all this disease
season and natural
biology kind of stuff.
And do you have some favorite
books you could recommend?
MIRA GRANT: I highly
recommend reading
the "Return of the
Black Death, the World's
Greatest Serial Killer,"
which is actually
a book about the hemorrhagic
fever theory of the Black
Death.
It includes the primary
epidemiological evidence.
And it's considered
a pop science
book, which doesn't
mean it's bad.
It means that it's
written to be accessible.
So it does not assume that
you have a medical degree,
going in.
I actually do recommend the
"Hot Zone" by Richard Preston.
It's very dated now.
But it includes some
really good links
to primary and
secondary sources.
And it'll give you
a grounding in why
Ebola is terrifying,
but difficult to catch.
And not worth worrying
about more than the flu.
For parasites, take a
look at "Parasite Rex,"
which-- oh, you've
read "Parasite Rex."
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MIRA GRANT: Excellent.
That is a good thing.
Have you read "Ghost Maps?"
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MIRA GRANT: "Ghost
Maps" is the story
of John Snow and the
downstream pump handle
and the birth of modern
epidemiology, which is great.
AUDIENCE: Ghost what?
MIRA GRANT: "Ghost Maps."
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
MIRA GRANT: Also take a look
at the "Barbary Plague,"
which is the true story of
the bubonic plague in San
Francisco at the turn
of the 19th century
and why anyone who tells you
that San Francisco is not
a city built on
racism is an idiot.
We literally built a
fence around Chinatown
because people had decided
that all the bubonic plague was
coming out of Chinatown.
And the only reason
it was not burnt down
with all of its residents inside
is because someone pointed out,
at the last City Council meeting
before we lit the matches,
this might be bad for tourism.
Like they were literally going
to burn the Chinese residents
of San Francisco to
death, alive, because
of the bubonic plague.
Yay, racists.
So that's a super-fun book.
I love it a lot.
"Virus X" is good.
And then there's-- I think
it's called "Virus Detectives,"
is the title.
The true story of the EIF, the
Epidemic Intelligence Service,
which is the virus-- oh, yeah,
virus detectives at the CDC.
They are subbranch of
the CDC, whose job it
is to walk into the worst places
is in the world with a stick,
and go, let's see
if this kills us?
Nope.
Get a bigger stick.
They're great.
I love the EIS.
They are fantastic,
fantastic people.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So on Tumblr, Sarah
Rees Brennan recently
had a post about that
killing characters
off, which you commented
on, and threatened
to collaborate with her.
Which, sign me up
for preorders now.
But I'd love to hear you
talk about-- she started
to talk about-- this character,
I put him in there to get
killed off for
reasons X, Y, and Z.
MIRA GRANT: Yeah.
I tried that.
I tried that once.
I had this character who was
completely intended to die.
Like their whole
purpose was to die.
Every one talked about how
they were going to die.
They didn't die.
Their best friend dies.
I was a little startled by that.
I'm like wait,
what just happened?
My subconscious lies to me
a lot, like a lot, a lot.
Because it's the only
way that I will embark
on these 10-book series
without going nope,
I've got too much TV to watch.
So I will frequently
find myself getting to,
like, I'm 2/3 of the way
through with this book.
It's great.
I'm going to be
with the duo-- ah,
the ending is still
like 180,000 words away.
Has this been a
trilogy all along?
Because I don't let myself
understand the scope
of what I'm embarking on.
There's at least one
character whose life
was saved by a coin flip, which
means that another character's
life was ended by
the-- no, there's two.
There's two characters in the
same series, where I'm like.
I could kill person A, or I
could kill person B, A or B,
A or-- I'm going to flip a coin.
Sorry.
Which is interesting
because the coin really
likes killing white dudes.
I appreciate that.
I literally had a
position where I
had a Chinese American and
a Russian Jewish American.
And I flipped the coin.
It was like kill
the Russian guy.
Oh, sorry, Dave.
The person I named him
after was very put out.
So I'm not I'm not as
foreshadowy as Sarah.
But Sarah Rees
Brennan, who is lovely.
She's absolutely splendid.
She's this tall.
I'm only exaggerating a little.
She's actually 6 foot.
She is enormous.
And she is proportionate,
So she looks like you
have just taken someone
and sized them up on
the Sims height scaler.
Everything has gone.
She's not a tall, thin person.
And she's Irish.
And she has one lazy eye,
that sort of wanders about
and looks at other things.
It's not actually
looking at them.
But she'll tell you it is
because she's horrible person.
And when she's having
a bad day, she'll
get on the--
schlomp-- I need you
to read me Veronica
Mars porn over Skype.
I'm like, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
I can do-- you have come upon
a coping mechanism I can meet.
It's like having your
very own evil leprechaun.
And she is absolutely splendid.
I love Sarah to death.
And she's one of the
most bloody-minded people
I know that is not me.
We get along fabulously.
She's one of my favorite humans.
She's also a YA author.
So she gets a lot
of crap for stuff
that I get no crap for at
all, which frustrates us both.
Not because I want crap.
But because no one deserves
crap for things like,
I freely admit that
I wrote fan fiction
because I'm trying to
be aspirational for all
of the young women of the
world that might someday
want to become
professional authors.
I get people going, wow,
Mira Grant like fan fic.
And she gets people
going, plagiaristic slut.
And I'm like, how, wait-- no.
Sarah, come on.
We're going to leave now.
And she actually joins in.
When I say for science,
she'll be like yes.
Let's eat all of these
pies for science.
So we ate a lot of pie.
And Sarah is splendid.
If you like YA fiction
at all, or if you
have someone in your life
who likes YA fiction,
I really recommend her
Lynburn Legacy books,
which are the story
of a girl named
Cami and her imaginary
friend, who is not imaginary,
but is very, very hot.
And Sarah had written
the first of those
before we actually
became friends.
Which is why I will give
her endless oceans of shit
for the fact that there is
a rhyme about the Lynburns
in the Lynburn Legacy
that does not scan.
I'm like, no, no, honey.
No, no, no, no.
Your poetry has to scan.
That's what poetry is for.
Apple red, corn of gold,
and not everyone gets old.
Like no, no.
No, no.
We can fix this.
If you had just time traveled
six months into the future,
it would have been like
we are friends now.
I would have fixed it for you.
So I get to fix these
things for her from now on.
Sarah is splendid.
Sarah is best.
AUDIENCE: I know that
your oeuvre is broad.
But I want to ask you-- I
think of you most strongly
in the Newsflesh--
MIRA GRANT: Many people do.
AUDIENCE: --trilogy.
And I want to ask, of the
embarrassment of riches
of zombie media and literature
available, what do you like?
MIRA GRANT: Well, the problem
is in my reading tastes,
I am just as dichotomist.
Because I really love the
literary equivalent of the bad
B horror .
Like if you completely
commit to what you're doing,
I am with you.
I will follow you into
that dark, terrible place
of terrible, dark darkness.
But I'm like, oh, you're doing
something interesting and new
and I've never seen this.
Let's follow you into
the intellectual fields
of halcyon flowers,
which is bad.
I highly recommend the
"Raising of Stony Mayhall"
by Daryl Gregory, which
is essentially the zombie
Jesus book.
And it's a beautifully written.
It's absolutely ingenious.
I do like Jonathan Mabery.
He was a very, very sweet man.
And he has his "Dead of
Night," "Fall of Night,"
x of Night books.
Jonathan is a really nice
guy, who puts up with the fact
that I know that his
virology is crap.
And I give him crap for his crap
virology every time I see him.
He's like yes, yes dear.
Not all of us review.
[LAUGHTER]
I think that's meant
to be a compliment.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not.
But we can take it.
I hate mentioning
it in this context
because it kind of gives
away some of what it's about.
But the single best
book I read in 2014
was the "Girl With All
the Gifts," by M.K. Carey.
It is only out in
hardcover right now.
Though it is also an ebook.
If you see it in
a bookstore, it's
a very yellow-orange cover,
with just the silhouette
of a girl like this, against it.
And it's genius.
It's so good.
And I wish I wasn't telling
you as much about it
as the context of the
statement tells you.
But is so worth reading.
It is so worth your time.
And it is a beautiful example of
how gender equality in science
fiction doesn't have to
be a thing you work for.
One of my favorite movies of
last five years was "Wreck-It
Ralph," which, if you
look at "Wreck-It Ralph,"
they completely, effortlessly,
without any visible strain,
any compromisation of the
story, any unnecessary romance,
set up a thing where your
protagonist and your secondary
protagonist, who I can't
pronounce right now--
you have two men and two women.
In the antagonist camp,
you have a man and a woman.
And there's no effort.
There's no point where
you feel like, oh, they
made Taffyta a girl because
they wanted to have balance.
No.
They just made a
female character,
who was an absolute bitch.
And it's lovely.
And it's beautifully done.
And the "Girl With
All the Gifts,"
manages a very similar balance.
Where you're reading
through and going,
there is no character
who is in here
to be the dude, the
chick, the-- this.
They are just people who are
stuck in this bad situation
and trying to survive
this bad situation.
And it's beautiful.
This is absolutely lovely.
And then David Wellington, who
did Monster Island trilogy--
he did "Monster Island,"
"Monster Nation,"
"Monster World"-- has
a new book coming out.
Which I just blurbed for him
and I'm very excited about.
And it is called--
I don't remember
what it's called,
which is terrible.
Because it has no cover.
And the covers are
what I always remember.
But it's David Wellington.
And he is great.
So I see people looking
at watches and such.
So I assume you
have work to get to.
Do we have any other questions
before I sign books and we
all-- oh, yes, we have
one other question.
AUDIENCE: So where did you
get the Mira Grant name from?
MIRA GRANT: It's
kind of fun there.
It is a combination of factors.
I wrote down every last
name I could come up
with that had one or more
references to classic horror
and science fiction movies.
And it was purely movies.
I stuck with those.
And then I wrote out a
bunch of first names.
And take them to my editor.
Because my editor
had said he really
wanted me to have a
pseudonym for these books
for very valid reasons.
And said I want to
be Samantha Grant.
And he said, OK, the
dot.com is unavailable.
Can we get the dot.com The
dot.com for Samantha Grant
is being camped by a soccer mom,
who has not updated since 1994,
and would not give
me her domain.
I don't mind you having
the domain of your name.
But maybe update it.
And when you're coming
up with a pseudonym,
it turns out that being
able to get the dot.com
is a hugely important factor.
So we went down the first
name list and we hit on Mira.
I have not had anybody
find both of the directions
that they came from, for
which I am sad, so sad.
People will sometimes hit on one
or the other, but never both.
So sad.
But, also, Mira Grant is
great because my last name--
my real last name is
McGuire, which when I sign,
is a great big M and a C and
a great big G and a squiggle.
Mira Grant is just a great
big M, a dot, a great big G,
and then a squiggle.
So it made my signature
much easier to come up with.
So thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]